So, you think what President Sunday did
to Not So Erudite, you think that that
was fine?
>> [laughter]
>> Uh-oh. Are you Are you blacklisting me?
I'm thinking about disassociating myself
from every community where Duby is an
active chatter. Where Duby is still on
the server. I don't think I can handle
it anymore. Why did it get archived and
deleted? Um because I think you were
threatening to dox and harass anyone who
posted in there.
>> [laughter]
>> Guys,
a statement from the Snark Left. There's
a Snark Left statement today.
My goodness.
Do the Discord channels make it public
statements? Well, this kind of had to be
made unfortunately because when people
are lying about you, you do need to come
together as a group and just say
something, okay?
We'll read this real quick.
We'll read this one and then I'll go
through my own thread and then we can
get on with the stream and laughing and
having a great time.
What What am I talking about? This
server is a server I participate in. A
lot of the clippers are from this
server. A lot of people who chatter from
this server. This is like a This is a
server where we are basically like it's
like dark comedy, like a dark comedy
vibe, and we do a lot of clipping and
research for videos and stuff in the
server. It's like a lot of content
creators, a lot of clippers, a lot of
people who watch a lot of stuff. Okay?
It's people who like content, who talk
about content a lot.
Okay? And basically there are people who
are trying to smear this community
and make it look bad, and I'm not
interested in in furthering those
smears. Do you know what I mean?
Okay. Hello, this is the Snark Left, the
Discord community started in September
of last year, created for clips, tweets,
and commentary surrounding online
politics and drama. Our community
consists of content creators, editors,
clippers, chatters, and more. Recently
we've been faced with certain
accusations surrounding the nature of
our community, and we want to take a
moment to address these concerns.
Unequivocally, our community does not
and never has condoned or endorsed
doxxing, invasions of privacy, or
otherwise exposing the personal
information of any of the subjects of
the discourse or anybody. We take these
matters seriously, and the The of the
community is staunchly opposed to
participation in these behaviors.
Following recent public discussions
about our server, we took some time to
review many of our chat logs, and we
discovered two instances of improper
disclosure of PII, personally
identifiable information, in our server.
The first was an incident only a few
weeks after the server opened, when
there was minimal moderation or
oversight.
This incident regrettably went unnoticed
by server ownership. The second incident
was deleted immediately, the same minute
minute it was posted. Both users are
permanently banned from the server and
are not welcome back. Since our culture
is so clearly opposed So, furthermore,
we want to make it clear we have nothing
to hide because our culture is so
clearly opposed to these behaviors, we
recognize these accusations for what
they are, a bad faith attempt to create
a false equivalence. Painting our entire
community as a doxing server is
transparently just a tactic to discredit
our commentary and shield the subjects
of our criticism from accountability.
There's going to be some parallels here,
okay? We look forward to continuing to
engage in critical satirical commentary,
promoting the work of our community
members, and most importantly,
Starking. Stark snark. Stark Stark
snark. Apparently, there's a funny
Stardust monologue. Give me a second.
So, a couple of things to keep in mind
here. For [snorts]
the past year and a half, people have
been sweeper hunting, which is basically
if you have been associated with Destiny
at any time at any point, uh people were
doing this thing for the past year and a
half where they would show up in your
chats and demand that you disavow
Destiny and disavow everything, right?
And to you know, it didn't matter if you
disagreed with his actions, it didn't
matter if you criticized him for his
actions, it didn't matter if you'd
recently collaborated with him. They
would show up in your chat
demanding you say something
Dude, I don't I literally don't care.
Like, Stardust needs to just stop
coping.
Just stop coping.
By the way, there's lots of people who
associate with Destiny on a lot of
different grounds, right? The sad thing
about Stardust is she just hates me and
Kwebbelkop. She just hates the people
who don't like Destiny. She doesn't
actually like Destiny. That's even
worse. If you at least had a
relationship with Destiny, if he gave a
about you, this would be less pathetic.
But it's so much more pathetic when I
know it's just a petty personal
grievance.
Like just admit that that's what you're
doing. When you say, "Um, these guys all
pretend they're better." You're just
running Dan's narrative.
That's what Dan's been trying to say.
These guys pretend they're better, but
they're not. Uh, but we are though.
But we like actually are. Cuz here's the
thing,
at minimum, we have the principle and if
if something around us fails in the
principle, we call it out and we cut it
out.
Why is Why are all these people
pretending that when they say they they
say they don't have principles, that
makes them better? Actually, I'm just
not lying to you.
It's [clears throat] the inverse of the
hypocrisy thing. The hypocrisy and what
is it? It's the inverse of the hypocrisy
comment or or joke from
Norm Macdonald, that's who it is.
You know, the the thing about Cosby?
Like, you know, Pat Oswalt says to me,
"The worst part is the hypocrisy." It's
like, "No, the worst part is the
Well, guess what?
The worst part isn't the hypocrisy or
failing in a standard occasionally. The
worst part is the bad conduct and the
bad conduct that you say you're
unapologetic about.
So, don't try to compare us. We're not
the same. Shut up.
Jeez. Can I ask what you hate about
Destiny and Point Forum? I don't know
your past beefs well enough. He
threatens anybody who basically steps
against him in almost any way. Like if
you are pointing out a moral flaw of
his, he will threaten you naturally. Uh,
he threatened Anavar. He threatened to
basically, when his whole community is
coming down on Anavar, he threatened to
leak her nudes if she basically said
what she's right now while she was being
called a stalker by a bunch of people,
right? There's a whole bunch of things
like that. If you criticize this guy, he
will threaten you.
I criticized him, he threatened to dox
me.
He just threatens immediately, right?
And in a lot of cases, he actually
follows through. He's a sick, sick,
twisted person.
There, I actually did it really fast.
There you go. something about Destiny,
as if you hadn't. Right? You
It It basically they were looking for
sweepers so that they could basically
arrest them, right? And as somebody
who's like already on the outs or
outside of that community, like it
didn't really matter whether I was a
sweeper or not. They were already
labeling me as a sweeper
despite the fact that as soon as the
stuff with Pixie exploded, I was very
critical of Destiny for his actions in
that. Riding the waves with the Oreo,
right? That's all it was. And just
because I didn't want to make my entire
life about destroying his life. No,
that's not required.
>> Or even This is just totally made up.
Oh, just cuz I didn't want to make my
whole life about destroying his life. I
have a bunch of friends who literally
refuse to talk about Destiny. I wonder
why? I wonder why they're all so scared
to say something. But I've got a bunch
of friends like that. What are we
talking about? I've got a a whole bunch
of friends who want nothing to do with
any of this [__]
That's totally fine.
Why is she pretending this isn't about
her coming out and explicitly trying to
minimize his wrongdoing by bringing
everybody else down to the same level?
That's what she was called the sweeper
for, and that is an accurate statement.
You are a sweeper. Stop coping. circling
around his life. Like I was labeled as a
sweeper, which is insane. And what
happens to sweepers? They get harassed
and they get doxed, right? And if they
determine that you're
enough of a sweeper or they get enough
evidence of it, they'll they'll just dox
you, right? So, for the past year and a
half, people have been doing that, and
it's like a guilt by association thing,
right?
And the point of this call that we're
about to listen to is there has been
discovered the Snark server, a splinter
Discord server where people are
doxing people, um coordinating
harassment, coordinating smear
campaigns, and Contend with the
criticism, point out what the criticisms
are lies or false, contend with the
criticisms. That's what you got to do.
Discontent with the criticisms. Again,
we operate That community operates on
the Cat Piss Manifesto standard. You're
responsible for the things you do. If
people break the rules, and doxing is
against the rules, they will be banned.
Show me an instance of somebody of it
going unmoderated outside of the one
that's in September where we like missed
it, right?
Otherwise, [__] off. Don't pretend that
one member of your community doing
something bad over months and months and
months is indicative of that entire
community. I say we cuz I don't like
minimizing like my
the membership of the group, obviously.
Right? Stop. Just stop. If If we're
banning people if they do something like
this, that's the line. That's the
standard. You have to inform me and let
me moderate it.
This whole thing where it's like, "Oh,
we actually know this is all happening,
but we will never prove it." [__] off,
man.
[__] off. Oh, and actually, hold on.
There is another thing that I wasn't
necessarily going to say,
but I wouldn't say I don't feel bad for
people who do get their information
revealed if they've done bad acts. I I
won't say I don't feel bad for them. I
basically almost always feel empathy for
people even if they're really
But I don't know how you participate in
these communities for the past 14 months
as Destiny has gone on a doxing campaign
providing no evidence for that doxing
campaign targeting me, Queen Man, my
community,
uh
just a bunch of people, a bunch of
different people, right? And you don't
speak up and demand the evidence. None
of you guys spoke up and demanded the
evidence. Not a single one of you said,
"We need to see that evidence, or I will
not engage with you anymore." And it's
led to where we've gotten to now in
terms of escalations. And so, while I do
feel bad for you guys getting your
information exposed, and I would never
support somebody doing that, you have to
understand that you played the most
pivotal role in that happening to you.
You could have come out and said,
"Actually, Destiny, I'm not going to I
will literally block you from everything
and never interact with you again unless
you show me why you're doing this." And
it's never happened. Not a single one of
these people stood up and said, "Hey,
this is wrong and we can't just let you
punish people or or try to meet out
punishment to people without evidence.
If anybody had stood on business and
said and drawn a a bright line in the
sand,
you wouldn't be here now.
You're here now because you've been
appeasing this lunatic for 14 months or
something now at this point.
That's why we've gotten to where we've
gotten to.
I got I don't care about Star Hust. It's
our last day of this stuff, guys, and
then we're going to I just got to I just
got to watch Duby style on people, okay?
I just got to watch some Duby.
>> we're doing a lot of drama, okay? I'm
trying to have this drama going for days
and days.
Um are you going to recap the Duby stuff
from the VC last night / this morning? I
don't think there were recordings
floating out there. It's just
one of the Dude, it's he is like so he
can't cover it on his stream. He does
not want this in a VOD on his stream,
that conversation. That conversation is
like crazy. The one of the conspiracies
that people spread about me is that like
the second I found out this girl that
was involved in my lawsuit was underage,
the moral and upstanding citizen thing
to do would have been I needed to go to
the FBI, give them a whole bunch of
and say, "Here, FBI, like I think you
guys need to investigate all of this
stuff because um I you know, I want to
be a good Samaritan." How like just it's
like the most thing in the universe,
okay? I tried asking Duby a couple
examples of like would you ever do this?
And like Duby was saying that like um
Duby was saying that
I think the
Duby was saying that he did it. Duby was
saying that he had multiple examples.
Duby gave you multiple examples of doing
it, actually.
Give them a whole bunch of So, you had a
whole bunch of then. They just WANTED ME
TO GO GIVE MY TO THE COPS. NO, it's
mine. It's mine. Gross. Gross behavior.
>> I said? I said if you if you have a
friend who gives you like a ton of [__]
and it ends up being like a bunch of
drugs or something and then you realize
it's a bunch of drugs. Like would you
take all of these drugs to the cops and
go, "Hey cops, I have like kilos of or
whatever. Um I just wanted to like give
this to you and let you know that like
there's a bad guy out there, but I
didn't actually
Hold on. That's a weird example. You
might not have to go to the cops with
that depending on what you could do,
right? Like you could just report your
friend. The issue is here
you need like the evidence to get the
like somebody could be getting harmed.
You you have said the solo guy is an
international trafficker. He could be
harming more young girls, right? That's
the framing you gave us.
If that is your framing that this guy is
potentially very harmful to a bunch of
other people on the internet,
then you you should, yes, obviously do
that. He wanted any of it, but he just
gave it to me. Like it it it's just like
the most thing. It's just like the
Yo, teach chatter. Thank you for the 30
months. Let's go.
>> like all these stupid
hypotheticals to run down. And then the
thing that I have the issue that I have
is that Doobie will spend like I I just
jumped into the beginning of stream.
Doobie was also in that Discord server
this morning talking about me. I think
he was in that Discord server last night
talking about me. Doobie spends hours
and hours and hours and hours and hours
um
like an
Patriot. Patriot. Doobie.
Doobie's a patriot.
Patriot. in all these servers I'm in.
>> okay? Um I think I'm probably for the
first time like I'm close to this. I
have to think about it a little bit more
tonight, but for the first time I think
I'm probably going to
enforce a no contact thing, but I don't
know if it's going to be like cutting
out like Wick or Connor or whatever
else.
>> Oh, here we go. Here we go. So, Destiny
comes on his stream today and he goes,
"Guys, today I'm really going to do a
blacklist today. I know I've copped out
every other time I've ever done a
blacklist ever, but like today I'm
really going to do a blacklist today,
okay? Today is a real blacklist day. I
mean it. I'm I'm not just infinitely
raging. I mean it. I mean it. I mean it.
I might just cut people out who still
allow Doobie to go to their servers and
talk and talk and talk and talk and talk
about me being a whatever for hours and
hours and hours because it's not just
that too. Like I've heard him make this
argument multiple times and he was doing
it again this morning to where um
Doobie argues that like if I'm in favor
of doxxing or unmasking certain people,
Jesus, hold Okay, sorry. Never mind. If
I'm in favor of like doxxing or
unmasking certain people because I think
that like I think that this identity is
relevant. I don't think this person
should be able to do something for 20
uh you know, months of stalking me uh
and completely be able to walk away from
it and like there's no identity. It's
just like a faceless person. I think
that's crazy, right? Um he his argument
is that well, couldn't one of these
people whose names that you uncover,
couldn't they have like a family? And if
that person has a family, you're
basically doxxing a family, which means
that you're uh you're basically creating
a world where I think it would actually
be permissible to dox my son and his
mom. Like he's around here making these
arguments.
>> permission
I structure um permission
permission structure for people to [__]
with an atheist and just [__] with his
mom and I don't agree with that to be
clear.
Oh. Oh, like when you dox adjacents of
people, you are creating a permission
structure for people to go after your
adjacents, right? When you when you dox
collateral targets to the people you're
upset with,
you are creating a permission structure
to go after your own collateral targets.
Yes, absolutely. That's That's just
obviously true.
If you're somebody who engages in an
action and most people say, well, I
think that action is wrong, you will get
a significant number of people who will
not hold their principle and will say,
no, I'm going to do the thing back to
you that you're doing to me.
That like principally, it's not good,
but obviously, you are like for other
people to go, well, that's totally wrong
to do,
but you do the thing, right? It's very
difficult. I think Destiny has even
agreed with this in the past. He agreed
with it in the doctrine front, yeah.
He said yes to this.
Like while while Kweiman argued that, I
think Kweiman argued that in the He did
a video response to Willy, right?
Like that is the Destiny argument is I
can go after all of these adjacent. I'll
threaten all of these adjacent, and you
just have to deal with it.
Yeah. That's That's just on the
He put that on the board. Now, we don't
do that because it's wrong to do that,
but he's the one who put that on the
board. It's It's
It's just I don't think any of it should
be happening. But I just want to be
clear like if if that is what the world
that he's he
is creating, like I don't think he has
any ground to complain about it. Well,
wait. So,
uh first there's like two things here.
It's just like whenever like we're
talking about some like unhinged
person's behavior, you're always
pointing out like, well, but kind of
like but Destiny did this. And then it
doesn't even seem that equivocal. Where
did Destiny tell you it's okay to dox
people's families, children, or any of
that? Like it's It's just a loose
connection where this guy is like
directly saying
I mean, hold on. I can see Oh, he
presented this so disingenuously, didn't
he? He's like, actually it gives you a
permission structure to like go after my
son. I'm guessing what Doobie's going to
say is, technically, it's giving you a
permission structure to go after like
adjacent content creators, but if those
people had kids, then you would be
doxing the location of them, right? If
if that were to happen. Like if you were
if somebody were targeted and they had a
family, and their information was posted
online, well, their family are now like
openly at risk.
That's the problem. saying like, hey,
it's okay to like Yeah, it's okay to
like target If if you get or
what you're saying is basically in by
Destiny's standards, it's
uh
by Destiny's standard it it
an internal critique of the people who
associate with Destiny, right? That
you're you're associating with a
community that has these standards, and
so you are opting into something, you
basically have no right to complain.
Right? If something immoral is done to
you. Now, I don't engage in that. People
around me don't engage in that. But like
these people when they get up in arms
about this, it's like, "Dude, you you
opted into this." And like I said
earlier, I actually feel bad for these
people who have had their PII exposed. I
do. But if you guys had stood up to
business months ago, months and months
and months ago and said, "Hey, you you
can't come on my stream until you show
evidence for this while you're like
doxing people."
If I'm not going to associate until you
show evidence for this. If all these
people had done that,
they wouldn't be in this situation.
They didn't do the right thing. They
made an immoral choice. And that immoral
choice has led to now.
And so while I feel bad for them, and I
don't advocate for any of those things
to happen. In fact, I advocate the
opposite. I would say, "Hey, you
actually hurt the the people who are on
the other side of this are probably hurt
actually by PII being exposed to people
who are adjacent to Destiny. That he
uses that to isolate people or to sorry,
insulate people to push them further
onto his side of things, right?"
Like I would say, both pragmatically and
morally it's wrong. But I I don't I
don't control the people who do it, so I
can't make them stop. I would like for
them to stop.
I Okay. Hold on. I got sent some
screenshots of
I think I got I got sent some
screenshots here real quick
of this argument, okay? So there was an
argument between Big Nick, Erudite's
husband, Big Nick.
Almost people told me he said, "You said
people are justified in going after
Destiny's kid." On the doxing thing, I
think any large internet community is
going to be full of nut bags who do dumb
[__]
Doxing is and should be a taboo with
zero tolerance in online spaces for this
reason.
Over the last couple years, Destiny's
been openly engaging in doxing and
encourage the encouragement of her of
doxing. Oh, he claims this is in
retaliation. I claim that isn't true.
I've never doxed him or encouraged
anyone to do that or hung around people
doing it. Now we continue.
His behavior has broken the taboo in a
way that we we haven't seen in these
spaces. We just haven't seen it in these
spaces. So, if he's going to behave this
way, understanding that the these spaces
are full of nut bags on all sides who
might endanger the families and loved
ones of his enemies, he should expect it
to happen to him. I don't think any of
it is justified. I think it's all bad
and everyone should stop. I think even
if he's doing it to other people, people
should not do it to him and especially
not his friends or family. I've
absolutely never supported involving his
son and family in any of this stuff and
I never would.
Okay? Okay? Okay? Okay? And basically
Nick comes back and says, "Wait, I
should clarify. Are you saying that he
has no right to complain or that he
should blame himself? I think those are
substantially different. I'm not sure
which one you mean."
Um he is to blame for creating the
permission structure and
those are the same, right? You have no
right to complain because you have a lot
of blame in the situation. I think the
Are those really different? I'm trying
to I'm not even thinking about why those
are different. To me, on its face, I'm
like, "No, the reason he should blame
himself or the reason he shouldn't
complain is because it's like at least
partially, largely his fault. Like he
has basically made it so other people
get this like feeling that he deserves
it and they go after him, right? But if
it's all taboo as it's been for a very
long time, you see far less of this
stuff occurring."
Okay.
It's no It's normal when you like
Destiny. More normal than shoe stalker.
Haha. Okay, not just by it. Yeah, I can
use myself as an example. I've been to
the multiple actually dangerous criminal
orgs for a decade now who have made
serious threats against my family and I.
Destiny's encouraging people to doxx my
family or doxx me puts my family
Destiny's encouraging people to doxx me
puts my family at risk. Me, too, but I
care less about that. I think you would
understand if I reacted to that danger
in a very aggressive, violent, or
problematic way.
But I will not do it because I'm
mentally stable I'm a mentally stable
person and I've done enough to feel
decently safe from the doxxing threats.
But not everyone is me. So, like I don't
know, seems like he's playing with fire.
I hope my last statement clears it up a
bit. It's not what I think It's not that
I think any of this is justified. It's
more that I think his behavior is
fueling this kind of unhinged behavior,
and he needs to stop fueling it. Yep.
Destiny needs to be the bigger human. Is
he capable? Literally never. Destiny is
incapable of being the bigger bigger
human both because of his stature and
like morally, he's just He will always
lower himself below whoever he's going
against, right? He'll always lower the
standard. He always lower the bar every
single time.
So, I think from here we can go forward.
We now got the his whole reiterating of
the blacklist. All right, 1 hour 36 11,
he's apparently confronting the
snarkers.
Let's see.
The next time stamp I've got.
Stacey is in Wick Court right now.
Oh, boy. Who's Stacey? [laughter]
One of the unhinged gesticulators.
Wait, [snorts] why are all of these
people just
I don't By the way, I think that's Wait,
Stacey?
Just being like a uh Oh my god, is that
what you actually sound like? Holy [__]
What are we doing? Are we doing more
reputation rehab for you guys in here?
Is that what's going on? Yeah. Uh we're
going over this tweet that Stacey or
this uh Discord log looks like uh Stacey
had here.
Yeah.
>> Is he Is he streaming right now? Are we
streaming?
>> We sure are. Are they Are they in a
streamable Discord when they're doing
this, by the way? Does anyone know if
they're in a streamable Discord while
this is happening? Is Wick just going to
totally kneel on his own rules here? I
actually like Mr. Moon.
Uh yeah, no, we were just talking about
how this snarker left's Discord's now
open. And uh trying to figure out uh why
would we want to go over there?
Wait, so just curious, Stacey, why did
uh Sava never get banned from Jessica's
Discord server for harassing
the victim of my court case?
Did you ever talk to Jessica about it?
I don't think so. And Chuck, you
wouldn't say anything? You would just be
like, oh, it's over.
Yeah, I would probably repull that, but
like in terms of having Cybert there, I
don't know what
what the correlative there is. Well, the
correlative is him posting emails of him
harassing a crime's victim and then
people like you responding favorably to
it.
Well, I responded favorably before I
knew what all of the emails were.
What? So, So, I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
By the way, this is what Destiny does is
we didn't even know Cybert had contacted
like any family or anything. It just
looked like he was letting her know you
got doxxed and here's how you take your
[__] down. at all cuz I think it got
archived or deleted or whatever. Why did
it get archived and deleted?
>> Um because I think you were threatening
to doxx and harass anyone who posted in
there.
Let's go. Let's go. Yes. That is That is
it. We basically I was basically playing
with the idea that maybe if we don't
have the shadow anymore, maybe this guy
will stop being a total psycho. Maybe.
Maybe. Maybe. Are you making it up?
Successfully doing that with eSports
Batman, right?
I don't think I ever did, did I? Did I
find him?
>> [laughter]
>> Did I I don't think I did that. I don't
think I did that. Oh, not so Suddenly,
the guy, once he knows that we're
willing to report him for for his
doxxing his crowing about his doxxing
and how effective it is, suddenly he's
like, oh, uh I'm not going to say
anything about this on YouTube.
Oh, so now you think it's wrong? I
thought you were the guy who was honest
about this, Destiny. I thought you were
out in the open about this.
Loser. Presumably, you did post this
doxx. You did put it into DGG chat. You
did say, "Here's eSports Batman's
information, lmao." Okay. I just don't
remember. But if I did, I mean, Did
what? I don't
Did I do that? Oh, I don't remember if I
did that. He's a lawyer. He's
credentialing himself. I think it's okay
for him to be unmasked to have a person
who
Don't call it unmasking. You are
publishing it publicly for the purpose
of harassment. It's not unmasking. You
Dude, he's doing the Israel thing. This
guy, as he spirals further and further
into his his own mania, he becomes more
like Israel, okay? It's that It's that
curse that burned the Israel patch into
his beard. It's just like his actions
become more and more Israeli over time.
Now he's like doing the the language
games, right? I just unmasked people. I
didn't I didn't dox. I just unmasked. I
It was unmasking.
Are Are we unmasking?
>> who is standing by their credentials and
then using that to weigh in on a court
case? I think that's totally fair. We
can disagree on that. That's fine. So,
do you think it was acceptable? What
emails do you think were acceptable for
members of a Antifa Discord to be
shooting off to a victim in my court
case?
members of an Antifa
He wasn't operating as a member of the
Discord.
He was operating on his own. Yes. Like
what kind of emails do you think would
have been okay that you were supporting
before you knew what they actually were?
I didn't have any of the details of the
emails. I think it was literally just a
descriptive
this person like removed
As far as I was aware at the time when I
said it, it was like
uh well, what's the word? Reciprocal. It
It wasn't like harassment in any to any
degree as I understood at the moment.
You don't think it's fair that somebody
could identify themselves as a lawyer
and then weigh in on a court case
uh in a community that has been like
publicly and privately engaging with
said court case and it's okay for that
person to remain anonymous the entire
time despite credentialing themselves? I
don't think that's worthy of a dox. No.
I I think you should be able to weigh in
on basically anything with
If you have a problem with that, you
could find their identity and report
them, right? Wouldn't that be the
direction you go? If you If you really
truly had a problem with it and felt
they were giving some opinion that was
worthy of of like raising a stink about,
why wouldn't you just report them?
There is no justification for publishing
it except to harass them out of
commenting.
dunce
This guy gets that that pointy cone cap
and he gets to sit in a corner all day.
Hey, dunce.
Obviously, there's no reason to publish
it publicly, you weird loser.
Like, every single time he's doxxed
somebody, which he has doxxed people,
right? Not unmask people, but doxxed
them, because he publishes the identity
publicly for the purpose of harassment.
He's like the ding-dong guy, yeah. He's
got the dunce cap.
>> Some level of anonymity.
You think you should be able to
credential yourself?
>> should be able to commit I don't think
you should be able to commit crimes, but
I think you should be able to like
publicly say something about something,
yeah. And you after credentialing
yourself? What counts as credentialing?
I could be completely anonymous. I could
say I'm a lawyer. I could completely
[__] lie.
>> say you're let's say you're a doctor and
you want to comment on a medical thing.
You're like, "Well, I'm a doctor, you
know, I'm a practicing physician." Do
you think it'd be fair for somebody,
especially if you're actively commenting
on a on a community that's actively
engaged with it?
There's no reason to publish it. You
could have verified their lawyer. If you
If you're worried about that, you could
have verified their lawyer and said,
"Yep, they're a lawyer." Which you've
already done in the past. You know that
he's a lawyer because your platform
verified him as a lawyer. Lying scum.
Oto lying scum again. You knew he was a
lawyer. You knew for a fact he was a
lawyer. You weren't looking it up. You
weren't trying to find out if he was a
lawyer or not. You knew that for a fact.
He was literally verified on your
platform. He has been in your community
for like 15 years. You are degenerate
lying scum.
that. You don't think it's fair for
people to like, "Well, who are you?" I
think that's kind of like an important
thing to know if you're going to
credential yourself as a physician. I
think it's like publicly worthwhile to
have
you know, at least the knowledge this
person is who they say they are. No?
So, you knew that this person was a
lawyer before you had their information?
Not 100%. I mean, he says he is, but
Okay.
So, then anyone who says that they're a
lawyer online and they comment on any
particular case whatsoever, you think
that that's fair game to like doxx them
all?
I think that if they are credentialing
them You just called again for a Pisco's
doxx cuz he's a sick
And they're they're like tons and tons
of active conversations about a
particular thing, I think it's fair to
unmask that person, yes. If somebody
shows up in one comment and they're like
"Hey guys, I'm a lawyer. This seems like
kind of, you know, kind of weird or
whatever." and like that's it, probably
not. But if somebody like for hundreds
of thousands of lines of text is
constantly giving an opinion and
feedback on like ongoing motions and
everything related to a court case that
a community is like actively, literally
actively participating in the court case
in, I think it's super fair to know like
that is that person at least the lawyer
that they say they are? I think that's
fair, yeah. So, just published that
they're a lawyer. You verified it.
Why Why would you need to do anything
beyond just go "Okay, this guy is a
lawyer. He can make these comments."?
Why did you have to publish his
identity? Why did you publish his
identity?
Why would you do that, Destiny?
It's obviously just to harass somebody,
right? Is Yuri a sick, degenerate
pervert who enjoys hurting people? And
we're just here to watch and and comment
and make a record.
We'll keep doing that. So, you think
what President Sunday did to No So
Erudite, you think that that was fine?
What do you think my issue was with the
President Sunday?
The No So Erudite stuff.
>> [screaming]
>> I'm I'm asking you now.
My understanding was the stupid thing
about the President Sunday thing was
that
I think Kyla says she I don't even
remember this. It's she was like she I
don't even remember, but like I think it
was something like
uh It's like a master's in econometrics
and then President Sunday with
>> [screaming]
>> Is he performing this? He has to be,
right? There's no way his memory's this
bad.
That's like his friend. That's somebody
who's supposed to be like his friend. If
If my friend couldn't even get remotely
close to the degree I have, like to the
credentials I'm I'm claiming I have,
I would
This person has no investment in you.
Either he's lying to pretend he doesn't
remember all that well, or he's just not
that invested in Erudite, the person
who's like constantly gone to bat for
him over years and years and years.
Right?
Like yeah, his podcast co-host, his like
long-time friend, he just doesn't give a
[__]
That's very funny to me.
>> Was trying to expose her as actually
only having like a graduate honors post
thing in econo psych.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude. Dude, there's no way. Dude, if
Stardust was doing this to him, he would
lose his mind, guys.
>> it metrics. It was like the whatever.
This was like the thing about the whole
President Sunday But isn't Kyla's name
like a totally graduate honors post
thing in econo psychometrics. It was
like the whatever. This was like the
thing about the whole President Sunday
But isn't Kyla's name public? It wasn't.
Or at least she was saying it wasn't.
So, they were saying that Sunday doxxed
her. So, you would just totally disagree
that Sunday doxxed Kyla. Therefore, like
every argument made about that whole
drama, you absolve Sunday of. Okay,
thank you. That was the argument. They
were saying Sunday like doxxed this
person.
Okay, well, I All right.
>> was public. I think what
President Sunday was trying to do was
verify uh what she was like doctored in
or whatever, and then trying to figure
out exactly like what she could consider
herself, and that he made the allegation
that she was lying about what she was
labeling herself, right?
>> Sure. Which I don't really think was
true.
I I don't know to the tenacity of that.
I'm just double-checking that the
standard is is that if you claim to be
something and you're commenting on
things cuz Kyla would often say, "Oh, as
a say whatever she called herself." I
don't remember the two terms that
President Sunday was
trying to identify.
By the way,
by the way, would this not also go to
the Nicandro's argument, the Nicandro's
and Chimmu argument along looking up
information on somebody because you have
like concerns about them? So long as you
don't publish it, right? Like it's not
Destiny would have to argue was it
improper for Sunday to look into this,
yeah?
>> You're saying like that that behavior is
fine. Trying to figure out exactly what
that is, and then trying to speak on
that with your credentials is actually
fine to go and look that information up.
>> Sure.
If somebody's credentialing themselves
in like mental health or whatever, sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh I I don't have much else time. Okay.
Have a good night.
>> Have fun. Good luck talking about me for
hours and hours in VCs more. Bye. Are
you uh are you blacklisting me? I'm
thinking about dissociating myself from
every community where Dubious is an
active chatter where Dubious is still on
the server. I don't think I can handle
it anymore.
Like
I understand your point here, and I
actually agree with it that these people
going in and kind of creating these
rumors constantly and spreading like and
basically litigating
why you are evil 24/7 is is a problem. I
I agree with you 100%.
By the way, I would assume Dubious like
me. I'll go in and just chill.
But the problem is
the cultists can't just chill if you're
there. They see an evil name, and they
have to come fight you, right? That's
the That's the real issue. I'm totally
fine not discussing the stuff, but if I
go in any VC that's like in some neutral
space
the cultists have to come in and like
fight you immediately. Like they see my
name in one of those spaces, they're
immediately in there like, "You're a
piece of me."
Do you, man? Do you, man?
It's so funny. Anyway,
I I Guys, I
Destiny, uh
if you're blacklisting me, and uh
I just want to say
I would you be doing that? I just don't
think that that's like a
very good question, a very good solution
to our problem here, Destiny.
I just don't Yeah. I mean,
just
I don't think it helps or will fix any
issue by just blacklisting anyone that
has any of these people in their server,
right? I disagree. I think that's I
think it's a really effective way of
doing things, and I think that's why
that's their MO. Like that's their
entire goal, right? What is Do you agree
that Dubi is trying to enforce a form of
blacklist against me with the way that
he donates to people, right?
I I think he's pressuring you. I don't
know if I'd say blacklisting, but it's a
definitely a pressure campaign and
manipulation campaign. I agree with
>> money, with thousands of dollars of
money, right?
Sure, but it hasn't worked in my case,
right? Like this is something that
they've been doing not just for a month,
not just for a couple months, but for
over a year now.
I should point out that when Destiny did
hot drop into that VC, I do believe
they were talking not about him.
Were they
Maybe it's a different one. Maybe it's a
different one later in the day. I think
he's done this a couple times, so
>> harassing me basically and trying to get
me to ban you uh and to not have you on.
Uh constantly harassing me by with my
own principles. Jeb Ted just keeps
harassing me with my own principles.
Dubi just keeps harassing me with my own
stated principles. It's harassment to
point out that I've totally changed on
this topic.
This is deranged harassment.
>> either by directly saying that like a
few community members uh or as Dubi does
and say, "I'm just not going to donate
to you when you have Destiny on." Um
that hasn't worked in my case. And so
if you're going to blacklist people
where communities this happens, I think
you should probably make an exception
for communities where it does not work.
And I think that Yeah, but what the
problem is when you say does not work,
the issue is that like [laughter] these
people are Dude.
Dude, what the
Hold on. I was giving a I was giving a
meme just for this moment. Hold on.
Hold on.
The Jeb Ted meme, Jeb Ted
threw this up, okay?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, suck your
You want to eat your I'll eat your
That's it's basically Wick when he is
confronted with Destiny, okay? He'll do
anything. He'll do anything.
Just don't
Just don't blacklist me. Just Just don't
blacklist me.
Please. so active. Didn't you see the
thread? I'm on your team now. Didn't you
see the thread? in these communities
talking and talking and talking and they
will bring their friends in to talk and
talk and talk. Like it was happening a
few months ago. Some people notice it. I
think the only like really well
moderated community that like protects
against this stuff is Loner Boxes. Some
people notice it but like four or five
will join at the same time. They'll be
in these VCs constantly talking about
me. And now like at this point in my
life where
The thing where that he's talking about
right now is me joining Loner Boxes
Discord to hang out with Marutzi and
playing World of Warcraft.
And then if people wanted to argue with
me, I'd argue about politics. That's
what I was there for. It was just to
argue about politics, right? Bring
people in to argue with me. I wouldn't
even I would explicitly try not to bring
it up as a topic. I would try.
>> it has had like a severe negative like
impact on like these people are direct
participants in my court case right now.
That's letting a actual trafficker just
like run free in the UK because they're
so
How does he say this today? After what
he said to Duby last night, how does he
moralize on this?
Letting this trafficker run free. How
does he How does he moralize it?
How? How? How?
We just listened to a VC last night
where he's like, "Yeah, of course I'm
not going to go to the cops with this,
Sam. That would be crazy. I could get
arrested for
Of course I'm not going to go to Dude,
what?
>> obsessed with like trying to talk about
me and participate in my case all the
time. I I just don't know why
I would want anything to do with
communities where these people are just
for 10 hours a day. You can't fight
against it. It's too much. It's too much
to constantly have somebody here. Like
these people are relitigating the Anna
Vor drama every single day. Cuz you lied
about it and you got her to lie about it
by remaining friends with her and now
she sees it clearly.
You literally commented on this. Britney
Simon leaked this about you, right?
>> 8-hour VCs. I get sent so many
recordings. Did you know there was
another 7-hour VC last night in this
politics room? There was another 6-hour
VC in Peace Coast. There was another
5-hour VC in Carter's. There was another
7-hour VC in Wix. Duby was in there last
night. Oh, you know how Vickers kept
bringing up like didn't you do this?
Wasn't this part of the mystery report?
That was Doobie sending messages to him
because he was in that voice chat. And
then he was there chatting for hours and
hours after the debate. He was there
this morning for when I woke up still
talking about me. And then before I went
to stream he was also in there talking
about me. Like yeah, I'm sorry. Look, I
I'm I'm going to be very clear with you.
I 100% am on your side and I do not
agree with Doobie and what he is doing.
But Doobie has been part of my community
for since since it began, since it
started. Um he is often in my VC and has
been since it started just to chat. He
Wick knows that if he like that his
community might just end up following
Doobie around.
>> often talks about you but not always
talks about you. Now, if you'd like, I
can consider something like banning
unless you're on my stream not letting
them talk about you, right? Like so if
they do start uh litigating uh oh, did
you hear about what Destiny did XY and
Z? Maybe we can put a nix on that. But
asking me to ban someone who hasn't
broken my rules, I don't I I'm just not
going to do that. Yeah, I don't know.
Maybe I'll think about it. But the the
issue is the way these people operate is
like if somebody says something good
about me in one of these VCs, they're
all going to be in their side Discords
like sniping at the person, talking
about the person. In some Discords maybe
doxing the person.
>> shown me the evidence that this is the
case. I 100% agree with this. Yes. Yeah,
but then why like I just don't know why
I would want to be associated
Like it's just like it's so much. Like
why?
Dude, I
What does Wick decide? I feel like Wick
knows that his community like quickly
disintegrates if he gets rid of Doobie
and Jab and a bunch of these people at
the same time, right?
He's got to know that.
I think. I think he's got to know that,
right?
>> know. It's just like a lot. It's just
It's a lot. It's a lot.
I get it.
Like
But But you understand like the on my
side of on my end of things, right? And
I I I get that like th- this isn't
something like you have to be altruistic
for or anything like that. But like I do
have a certain set of rules. I do have a
certain set of values. And one of my
values is I allow people to have
discussions in my server about even if I
100% disagree with them. Like again,
this is something that
they have advocated in my Discord over
and over again in a pressure campaign
against me, which again has not affected
It doesn't have the same ramifications
towards me as it does towards you. I
understand that. I'm not on trial.
I don't have a court case pending. But
it is something that they have been
pressuring me that has affected me. But
like one of my one of the reasons
initially I took your side before
knowing anything is because they were
asking me to ban others and you were
not. And I'm always going to side with
this the the people at least
Well, wait, who were they asking you to
ban? I think they were just asking you
to ban the person who was doing the
doxing, no? Wasn't Wasn't the person
they want to ban just Destiny because he
was doxing people actively?
I thought that was the only person that
he
would Were they asking to ban someone
else?
Is Is Wick pretending that they were
pressuring like Wick to ban DG community
members? At least initially who say,
"Hey, uh you can do what you want. We're
not going to try to to
uh pressure you or manipulate you in any
way, shape or form."
Um and That's fine then. In that case,
my my only request then I guess would be
to not ban the um streaming in that room
cuz now I'm just going to set an alert
up and if anytime these are talking
about me, I don't give a [__] if I'm
sleeping. I don't care if I'm at my
future wife's having a birth in the
hospital. Dude, oh my god. Could you
imagine being like a big streamer and
saying this out loud? Bro, that's crazy.
That's insane. Anytime people are
talking about me, anyone on the
internet, I'll show up and I'll debate
them right now. I'll debate them
anywhere. Anywhere they go. Anywhere
they go. I'll debate them immediately.
It's like
Bro, can you chill? Are you good? Are
you all right? Are you Are you doing
okay? Um
Jesus, we need
I was going to say a certain phrasing.
Can we get one of Destiny's friends to
just go do a check-in with him, just
make sure that it's okay, that he's
doing all right. Nothing's a problem.
Right? Can we just make sure of this?
I want to be able to jump in and talk to
him. I don't care if I'm streaming or
not. Cuz that like it can't be that
these guys are 24/7 constantly chatting
about me always. It's crazy. Dude, he's
crazy.
>> I understand that and I think you've
demonstrated enough that [clears throat]
that problem rule probably needs to
change for that reason. Because if
they're going to talk
um in my servers and that you have to be
able
able to respond. I get that. Let's go.
Wait, wait, turning his whole server
into a battleground for streamers? I
might have to rejoin. I think I will be
banned summarily, but I might have to
rejoin. I'm going to get in that.
We just join and stream the Discords?
Let's go. Um
Yeah. We can make a change for that
rule. Yeah, we can do that. I can do
that. But I Like I said, if
if it's ban this person who hasn't
broken any of my rules, I'm just I'm
just not going to. Oh, wait, wait, will
not ban Doobie. Wait, will not ban
Doobie. He'll change all the other rules
to keep Destiny around, but he will not
ban Doobie.
Uh-oh.
Destiny, if you're going to be a petty
tin pot dictator, if you're going to be
this small-minded dictator Ethan
Klein-like figure,
then I'll have to say no.
Okay. All right. Okay. I'll be careful.
Is there anything else I can help you
with today? Anything uh
You need Um no, not right now.
Okay. I'll talk to you later, Destiny.
But be careful. I'll let you bye.
Without a long-term partner, he's got to
get somehow, right? Without a long-term
partner, he's got to lean into the meme
somehow. And so it's inventing a
blacklist and then done it within a
what? Hour and a half period?
Yeah, that's crazy. Dude, he's making
the same face. Hold on, where's the mail
time clip? Is he making the same face as
the mail time clip? I think it's mail
time again.
There you go.
Hey.
All right, you got to work.